カリャリだ
まず社長の実験室へようこそ今日はね三大二野球が好きだと思うんだけど
こちらにピッチングマシーンがある
最後するドラマって165キロが出てるわけだか今日はね
バッティングセンターっていうのは行くのが大変だと思うよね
大変なんだよ
だが僕はこうなんかは編厩舎として近い将来誰でもね
頭だけで手軽にねバッティングませんが楽しめるっていう
まあそれと僕が先駆者というか名前であるですフロンティアというかね
あそういう先駆者でがまあ先駆けになれればいいなと思ってるって言わないこちらの
ピッチングらしいんでね
正直怖いんですけど
よろしくだけどから部屋でショッピングセンターやってみたですねやってございます
から様が飛んできて
結構当たるんですけどでもではまたーぼっくねこう
像はフォーマルの窓ガラスもあればまず学校なんて感じてねっ
やっていこうと思いますだけでまずはね実験で邪魔
マックススピードで今からあってるんでどれくらいの速度で飛ぶかというかまずフォッ
クスっておかなきゃいけないんで
命が危ないんでまず実際に僕が玉を入れて食べてみます
書きます
car
ずレンズ
マッツパワーゲーム
しまっています
やばいんでしょ
ああああああ
[音楽]
不安ござるぞ良い
ワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワン
ワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワン
ちょっと万寿台スマーターた使う
言われましたよ
tan
持っています
座部1年
しています
goreme
[拍手]
つかんだ色一眼中継ぎでします
2ん2ん俺さえよ俺会を
さあ想定します
uh
me
goo
持っていた
ああああああ
婚礼の日
どこ行ったん
早くいる
うわーこいっ
ストアカーン今度ぞ
busy とビジター
tg 母佳子
入っていません
よし行くぞ
[音楽]
皆さん
本当に真似しないでください